do you think that's a permanent break or
do you think there's always room for a
reunion there's always room for a
reunion they'd never say never at the
end of the day it's hard to predict the
future as we've learned so I won't say
never you know but at the same time I
will say I'm having a lot of fun doing
the solo thing Tyler is
suddenly having fun with his debuts
titled solo album
[Music]
hello
on a scale of one to ten how would you
rate your dance skills my dance skills
maybe a five six room a lot of room for
improvement okay but I still cut a rug
every now and then after a few drinks
and you know if I'm feeling feeling the
beat you never know
Tyler you are such a romantic so many
love songs on this album is Haley like
50 of this album more or less good
question you know I would say there is a
lot of love in this house there's a lot
of love in my life and between my wife
and the kiddos you know there's a lot of
love floating around our house and so it
does inspire the music what's her
favorite song on this album I would say
it's probably it's probably uh changed
over the last year depending on what
song I'm playing over and over and over
but uh she does love five foot now for
sure it's such a good one God makes five
foot nine brown eyes and a sundress also
on the album songs written with long
time Friends Thomas Rhett what does the
play date look like with your family and
his family
it looks stressful
because there's like 10 kids running
around and only four adults and we're
just like uh-oh and anytime we get
together with them it's a good time